welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and thor love and thunder is
confirmed to expand the asgardian
mythology of the mcu after avengers end
game the spoiler warning if you don't
want to see
any of the behind the scenes visuals
that are coming out but we now know
this story will be set in new asgard as
that colony becomes a tourist
destination
meaning really this movie should be
called thor for norse or towards gore
war or quark porn
and if you look closely you can see how
exactly this movie will pick up the
forgotten pieces of mjolnir
why jane foster becomes the mighty thor
and how this film will connect to the
guardians of the galaxy and even the
eternals so i'm gonna break it all down
but don't worry i'll leave out korg's
porn
it's just rocks let's get that out of
here cork might be watching
okay the latest images from the thor
four set show the constructed town of
new asgard
which as we saw in endgame is located in
townsburg norway
the location of odin's death hellas
destruction of mjolnir and that church
where odin had the tesseract hidden
until red skull found it and now in love
and thunder the location has turned from
a coastal fishing village to a
full-fledged tourist attraction and
theme park it looks like notice how one
structure reads
asgard towards aerial sightseeing with a
nearby viking boat
equipped with these seats with shoulder
harnesses that you'd see on a roller
coaster
meaning the asgardian residents might
use there as guardian magic to make this
boat fly
and give visitors a thrilling view of
the place and let's be honest this will
inevitably
lead to an actual version of this ride
at the avengers campus in the disney
parks a brilliant move by taikawatiti
allowing him to both make fun of this
kind of commercialization
while still profiting from it and this
all fits in with the other visuals we
have seen from the thor 4 set including
a theatrical stage where the asgardian
actors who played the counterparts to
the characters in loki's play in thor
ragnarok including chris hemsworth's
brother matt damon
and sam neil all come back here and now
joined by melissa mccarthy as
the stage actor version of hella all to
restage that cliffside scene in ragnarok
which actually took place
very close nearby to this now carved
into marvel steps leading up to the
boulders where odin sat
the moment he dissipated but to the
right of that is this park's
central attraction the mjolnir shrine
see they must have dug out the terrain
around the grass where the shards of
mjolnir fell to the ground
forming a kind of turf pedestal where
visitors can
marvel at the shattered uru kind of
something between the sword and the
stone at disney
and the shards of narceal the sword that
was broken in the lord of the rings and
the fact that they were
unable to lift the pieces of uru even as
broken chunks tells us that
odin's worthiness charm must still be in
effect similar to how narcille was still
sharp and really its brokenness was what
allowed sauron's hand to be cut off and
i believe that theme of
damage making one worthy will be the key
to how and why jane foster comes to be
able to wield mjolnir in love and
thunder because we know from that said
video that jane foster upon coming near
this mjolnir shrine
during some visit to this new asgard
park maybe when she touches one of the
broken pieces
jane will levitate and convulse
presumably with vfx lightning to be
added later
most likely the moment she transforms
into lady thor because in
other photos taken from this moment
she's looking jacked now when she's
floating jane actually looks a lot like
she did when she was possessed with the
reality stone ether in thor the dark
world and i don't think that's a
coincidence
that ether made her sick and now we know
love and thunder will adapt jason
aaron's the mighty thor
which natalie portman confirmed will
indeed include that plot point of jane
foster having cancer but in this film
will something in particular have caused
jane's cancer
and if you're impressed with that last
point i guess you can now call me
don voss the mafia boss i guess i've
been getting a little into the fact that
i have been playing the grand mafia a
massive multiplayer online real-time
strategy game for players 18 and up it
gets a little spicy the game immerses
you in the world of mafia including
street fights robbery money laundering
all the crime stuff in the grand mafia
you join a faction of other gangs with
your friends to help each other build
out your crime empires
because that's what gangster friends are
for some of my faction mates need help
with construction
so i'm gonna select help all and boom
there's my good deed for the day
you also do battle alongside your
faction members as you advance in the
game you unlock
new features including mini games like
blackjack or roulette you know
more gangster stuff and when you get to
level 9 of the game you will unlock
another mysterious beauty who can help
you
and then you build out your mafia with
enforcers to do your fighting like this
one
on rio she got a sword and a bare
midriff and she's totally gonna wreck
whoever opposes you other enforcers of
different skills including some that
buff your whole crew
there's just a ton you can do in this
game fight the campaign to win resources
upgrade your buildings you can even
smelt download the grand mafia with the
new link in this video's description
for the chance to win special in-game
gifts find me in the game and let's
become mafia bosses together
one thing we are learning about infinity
stones in the mcu
is that despite their atomization by
thanos the radiation that the stones
emitted
remains in the universe and still has
effects on people like captain marvel
got her powers from radiation that was a
step
removed from the space stone rather than
touching the tesseract directly and we
just learned in one division that some
similar process might have happened with
monica rambo because she seemed to
possess
a radiated physiology even before
passing through the west view hex border
some mysterious history with carol
danvers that we likely won't get answers
to until the marvels but
i've suggested that that radiation may
have been what caused her mother maria
rambo's cancer now in one division they
defined the hex radiation as cmbr cosmic
microwave background radiation
a form of electromagnetism that dates
back to the big bang
the moment that created the six infinity
stones so we know this type of radiation
is ancient and in fact the cosmic energy
that the
eternals wield in various forms may be
linked to that cosmic radiation from the
infinity stones
the eternals were created by the
celestials who we know from the
celestial east on the searcher in the
collector story and guardians of the
galaxy celestials were capable of
wielding infinity stones which is why
peter quill as the son of the celestial
ego
was also capable of wielding a power
stone it might even be the same kind of
radiation that ego used to give meredith
quill that brain tumor
yeah the gods of the marvel world not
the best people so far
which is why we got a god butcher in
this movie love and thunder's villain is
gonna be gore the god butcher played by
christian bale and i think we can expect
gore to be on a war path to execute all
gods and god
level beings of this marvel universe and
i suspect that might include an early in
the film scene with zeus played by
russell crowe in this film
assassinated by gore with his famous
weapon all black the necrosword a weapon
that we know can kill gods because
technically in the comics it's the same
blade that decapitated the celestial
that nowhere once was
and now i think the next of gore's
targets will be asgardians like thor and
valkyrie
as well as celestials eternals and
celestial descendants like peter quill
which explains his and the guardians of
the galaxy's involvement in this movie
and anyone else marked by infinity stone
radiation and that includes
jane foster after her exposure to the
reality stone
radiation that may have left her with
cancer but also
now makes her worthy of wielding a
reforged mjolnir due to odin's
persisting worthiness
charm that now powers up jane into the
mighty thor
that's how you get jane foster thor in a
plot with thor valkyrie and other
asgardians of new asgard
and the guardians of the galaxy as gore
the god butcher comes for all of them
comment down below with your thoughts on
this theory follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos
and check out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
you